So, let's build up to the answer in steps.
We know that if n=1, it just returns a single node.
If n=2, it's going to recursively generate
a single node for G1, a single node for G2,
then randomly choose nodes from those sets,
which in this case are just the only nodes that are there, so it'll choose them,
and then it connects them up.
So, that's what n=2 looks like.
For n=4, we have two n=2, right?
G1 and G2 are both going to be an n=2 graph.
Let me draw those.
Then, it's going to randomly choose one of the nodes and one of the nodes
and connect them up.
So far, it looks kinda like a chain in all these cases.
Let's go to the next case.
Again, for n=8, it has to generate n=4 graphs,
each of which has to generate a bunch of n/2 graphs,
which all look like this.
There's going to be some randomness about how they get connected up.
So, maybe in one of the times we call it, we get something like this,
and one of the times, we get something like this.
Then, we connect randomly the two n=4 graphs to get the n=8 graph,
and maybe that will be something like this.
So, in this particularly case now, we don't have a chain anymore.
We do, on the other hand, have a tree.
And in fact, this property continues as we get bigger and bigger graphs.
We're always connecting up some kind of tree structure
with some other kind of tree structure. Here, I'll draw another one.
And we connect up these two tree structures,
and that just gives us a bigger tree structure.
So, we get a nice, messy, recursively defined tree, but it's still a tree.